the basic problem with the US economy is
that they're not enough jobs and then
given that employers get to be picky who
do we want to offer a job preferably
somebody who already has one or who lost
a job only recently so the long-term
unemployed get ruled out have you seen
long-term unemployed like this ever in
your career know that we know that would
there's been nothing like this since the
1930s this is a this is a completely new
thing for almost everybody you know
people people who remember this in
America were children when they last saw
it is your greatest anger that the
long-term unemployed really don't have a
voice in Washington I think it's there
are many things I'm angry about but
that's certainly one of them yeah we
have millions of people who've just been
ruled out of the discussion and but the
way it is we can try to do things to
make them more employable but mostly
what we need is more jobs so that
employers have an incentive to go out
and look for qualified people even if
they aren't people who already have jobs
what level do you see is the proper
amount of growth that we need to begin
to really solve our labor challenges
well I'm of the belief that we have
slack in the economy best guess we don't
know this for sure but I think we'd
probably still have five or six percent
slack in the economy and we should be
taking that up fast we should be growing
you know when you when you're that deep
in the hole you should be growing
several points above the long-run growth
rate so we should be we should be having
four or five percent economic growth at
this point so when we look and say well
look great we're doing 2.5 that's just
showing how how far we've become
accustomed to how far we've become used
to really dismal economic condition